as writes about the effects of hormone
therapy on the aging process in number
seven ageless premiering at number 8 is
thunderstruck Eric Larson author of
devil in the white city tells the story
of how an inventor and a murderer's
lives collided in the late 19th century
in his memoir the life and times of the
Thunderbolt Kid Bill Bryson describes
growing up in Des Moines Iowa in the
1950s it premieres on the list this week
at number nine rounding out the top ten
is Barefoot Contessa at home the Food
Network's Ina Garten shares recipes and
suggestions for welcoming guests for
more information visit the Publishers
Weekly website at Publishers Weekly
dot-com last week's Time magazine cover
featured atheist biologist Richard
Dawkins and debate over God and science
next the science professor and
best-selling author argues that there's
no rational or moral reason to believe
in God in his new book The God Delusion
this is just over an hour
good evening my name is Douglas shed I'm
a professor of biology at round off make
a woman's college and I would like to
welcome to the college and to this
year's Philip there Memorial Lecture
this lectureship was established by the
colleagues and friends of Philip they're
the late Theodore Jack professor of
history at randolph-macon Woman's
College in recognition of his long
service to the College
the lectureship seeps seeks to bring to
the college distinguished lecturers in a
wide range of academic fields who will
continue professors there professor
there's-- own tradition of edifying and
challenging lectures I was fortunate to
have known professor Thayer he was a
wonderful larger-than-life free thinker
and he would have been delighted by the
person who will deliver the fair
memorial lecture this evening this
person is of course Richard Dawkins the
Charles Somani professor in the public
understanding of science at Oxford
University professor Dawkins was born in
Nairobi Kenya and moved with his family
to England when he was seven he studied
zoology at Oxford where he was tutored
by Nobel prize-winning Niko Tinbergen
and earned his doctorate at Oxford
between 1967 1969 professor Dawkins was
an assistant professor of zoology at the
University of california-berkeley in
1970 he was appointed a lecturer and
then in 1990 a reader in zoology at the
University of Oxford before becoming the
university's first charles somali
professor in the public understanding of
science in 1995 professor Dawkins has
been a fellow of New College Oxford
since 1970 this year marks the 30th
anniversary of Professor Dawkins's
landmark book The Selfish Gene in this
book in this book professor Dawkins
explained to a popular audience many
important new ideas and evolutionary
biology and did so in a way so
insightful that the book influenced how
a generation of scientists think about
evolution the book is truly a classic
and modern scientific literature
professor Dawkins followed The Selfish
Gene with a remarkable series of books
including the extended phenotype the
blind watchmaker my personal favorite
the river out of River out of
climbing Mount improbable unweaving the
rainbow a devil's chaplain the ancestors
tale and most recently The God Delusion
The Wall Street Journal said Professor
Dawkins his passion is supported by an
awe-inspiring literary craftsmanship and
the New York Times Book Review has
hailed him as a writer who understands
the issue so clearly that he forces his
readers to understand them too professor
professor Dawkins awards include the
silver medal of the Zoological Society
of London the Royal Society's Michael
Faraday award the Nakayama Prize for
achievement in human science the
International cosmos pride and the
Kistler prize he has an honorary he has
honorary doctorates in both literature
and science and as a fellow of the Royal
Society professor Dawkins is an
outspoken commentator on science
politics and religion and among the
world's best-known public intellectuals
we are delighted to have him here this
evening to discuss his new book The God
Delusion professor Dawkins
thank you very much is this microphone
working I hope and expect that the high
spot of the evening will be when you get
to talk in the question and answer
session but before that you have to
listen to me for a bit while I read just
a few passages from my latest book The
God Delusion to set the scene for the
questions I'm going to begin with the
opening of the book from chapter 1 a
deeply religious non believer the boy
lay prone in the grass his chin resting
on his hands he suddenly found himself
overwhelmed by a heightened awareness of
the tangled stems and roots a forest in
microcosm a transfigured world of ants
and beetles and even though he wouldn't
have known the details of the time of
soil bacteria by the billions silently
and invisibly shoring up the economy of
the micro world suddenly the micro
forests of the turf seemed to swell and
become one with the universe and with
the rapt mind of the boy contemplating
it he interpreted the experience in
religious terms and it led him
eventually to the priesthood he was
ordained an Anglican priest and became a
chaplain at my school a teacher of whom
I was fond in another time and place
that boy could have been me under the
stars
dazzled by Orion Cassiopeia and Ursa
Major
tearful with the unheard music of the
Milky Way heady with the night sense of
frangipani
and trumpet flowers in an African garden
why the same emotion should have led my
chaplain in one direction than me in the
other is not an easy question to answer
a quasi mystical response to nature and
the universe is common among scientists
and rationalists it has no connection
with supernatural belief I often hear
myself described as a deeply religious
man an American student wrote to me that
she'd asked her professor whether he had
a view about me sure he replied his
positive science is incompatible with
religion but he waxes he waxes ecstatic
about nature and the universe
to me that is religion but is religion
the right word
I don't think so much unfortunate
confusion is caused by failure to
distinguish what can be called
einsteinium religion from Supernatural
religion Einstein sometimes invoked the
name of God and he's not the only
atheistic scientists to do so inviting
misunderstanding by supernaturalists
eager to misunderstand and claim so
illustrious a thinker as their own the
dramatic or what a mischievous ending of
Stephen Hawking's
a brief history of time for then we
should know the mind of God is
notoriously misconstrued it has led
people to believe mistakenly of course
that Hawking is a religious man great
scientists of our time who sound
religious usually turn out not to be so
when you examine their beliefs more
deeply this is certainly true of
Einstein and Hawking one of Einstein's
most eagerly quoted remarks is science
without religion is lame
religion without science is blind but
Einstein also said it was of course a
lie what you read about my religious
convictions a lie which is being
systematically repeated I do not believe
in a personal God and I have never
denied this but have expressed it
clearly if something is in me which can
be called religious then it is the
unbounded admiration for the structure
of the world so far as our science can
reveal it does it seem that Einstein
contradicted himself that his words can
be cherry-picked
for quotes to support both sides of an
argument no by religion Einstein meant
something entirely different from what
is conventionally meant as I continue to
clarify the distinction between
Supernatural religion on the one hand
and Einstein Ian's religion on the other
bear in mind that I'm calling only
supernatural gods delusional that's the
end of the extract from Chapter one now
an extract from Chapter two the god
hypothesis the God of the Old Testament
is arguably the most unpleasant
character in all fiction jealous and
proud of it a petty unjust unforgiving
control-freak a vindictive bloodthirsty
ethnic cleanser a misogynistic
homophobic racist infanticidal genocidal
Phylis idol pestilential megalomaniacal
sadomasochistic capriciously malevolent
bully
those of us schooled from infancy in his
ways can become desensitized to their
horror a naive blessed with a
perspective of innocence has a clearer
perception Winston Churchill's son
Randolph somehow contrived to remain
ignorant of Scripture until evil in war
and a brother officer in a vain attempt
to keep Churchill quiet when they were
posted together during the war bet him
he couldn't read the entire Bible in a
fortnight
unhappily it has not had the result we
hoped he has never read any of it before
and is hideously excited keeps reading
quotations aloud I say I bet you didn't
know this came in the Bible war merely
slapping his side and chortling God
isn't God a [ __ ] Thomas Jefferson better
read was of a similar opinion the
Christian God is a being of terrific
character cruel vindictive capricious
and unjust it is unfair to attack such
an easy target the god hypothesis should
not stand or fall with its most unlovely
instantiation Yahweh nor his insipidly
opposite Christian face gentle Jesus
meek and mild to be fair this milksop
persona owes more to his victorian
followers than to Jesus himself could
anything be more more Koosh Li
nauseating than mrs. C F Alexander's
Christian children all must be mild
obedient good as he I am not attacking
the particular qualities of Yahweh or
Jesus or Allah or any other specific God
such as Bale Zeus or Wooten instead I
shall define the god hypothesis more
defensively there exists a superhuman
supernatural intelligence who
deliberately designed and created the
universe and everything in it including
us this book will advocate an
alternative view any creative
intelligence of sufficient complexity to
design anything
comes into existence only as the end
product of an extended process of
gradual evolution creative intelligence
is being evolved necessarily arrived
late in the universe and therefore
cannot be responsible for designing it
God in the sense defined is a delusion
and as later chapters will show a
pernicious delusion not surprisingly
since it is founded on local traditions
of private revelation rather than
evidence the god hypothesis comes in
many versions historians of religion
recognize a progression from primitive
tribal animism x' through polytheism
such as those of the Greeks Romans and
Norseman to monotheism's such as Judaism
and his derivatives Christianity and
Islam Christianity claims to be a
monotheistic religion you have to wonder
sometimes rivers of medieval ink not to
mention blood have been squandered over
the mystery of the Trinity and in
suppressing deviations such as the Arian
heresy arias of Alexandra in Alexandria
in the 4th century AD denied that Jesus
was consubstantial ie of the same
substance or essence with God what on
earth could this possibly mean you're
probably asking substance what substance
what exactly do you mean by essence very
little seems the only reasonable reply
yet the controversy split Christendom
down the middle for a century and the
Emperor Constantine ordered that all
copies of Ares his book should be burned
splitting Christendom by splitting hairs
such has ever been the way of theology
do we have one God in three parts or
three gods in one the Catholic
Encyclopedia clears up the matter for us
in a masterpiece of theological close
reasoning in the unity of the Godhead
there are three persons the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit these three
persons being truly distinct one from
another thus in the words of the
Athanasius God the Son is God and the
Holy Spirit is God
yet there are not three gods but one God
as if that were not clear enough the
encyclopedia quotes the third century
theologian st. Gregory the miracle
worker there is therefore nothing
created nothing subject to another in
the Trinity nor is there anything that
has been added as though it once had not
existed but had entered afterwards
therefore the Sun has never been without
the father nor the Sun without the
Spirit and the same Trinity is immutable
and unalterable forever whatever
miracles may have earned sin Gregory his
nickname they were not miracles of
honest lucidity his words convey the
characteristically obscurantist flavor
of theology which unlike science or most
other branches of human scholarship has
not moved on in 18th centuries Thomas
Jefferson as so often got it right when
he said ridicule is the only weapon
which can be used against unintelligible
propositions ideas must be distinct
before reason can act upon them and no
man ever had a distinct idea of the
Trinity it is the mere abracadabra of
the mountebanks calling themselves the
priests of Jesus
Jefferson heaped ridicule on the
doctrine that as he put it there are
three God's in his critique of Calvinism
but it is especially the Roman Catholic
branch of Christianity that pushes it's
recurrent flirtation with polytheism
towards runaway inflation the Trinity is
are joined by Mary Queen of Heaven a
goddess in all but name who surely runs
God himself a close second as a target
of prayers the pantheon is further
swollen by an army of Saints whose
intercessory power makes them if not
demigods
well worth approaching on their own
specialist subjects the Catholic
community forum helpfully lists 5120
Saints together with their areas of
expertise which include abdominal pains
abuse victims anorexia arms dealers
blacksmiths broken bones bomb
technicians and bowel disorders to
venture no further than the bees
pope john paul ii created more saints
than all his predecessors of the past
several centuries put together and he
had a special affinity with the Virgin
Mary his polytheistic hankerings were
dramatically demonstrated in 1981 when
he suffered an assassination attempt in
Rome and attributed his survival to
intervention by Our Lady of Fatima a
maternal hand guided the bullet one
cannot help wondering why she didn't
guide it to miss him altogether
others might think the team of surgeons
who operated on him for six hours
deserved at least a share of the credit
but perhaps their hands too were
maternally guided the relevant point is
that it wasn't just our lady who in the
Pope's opinion guided the bullet but
specifically Our Lady of Fatima
presumably our Lady of Lourdes Our Lady
of Guadalupe Our Lady of Maggio gory Our
Lady of Akita Our Lady of zeitoun Our
Lady of Garib and El and Our Lady of
knock were busy on other errands at a
time where chapter 3 debunks the
arguments for the existence of God
leaving that on one side chapter 4 why
they're almost certainly is no God is
hard to compress into a brief reading
and I'll have to leave that as well
chapter 5 is about the interesting
question why people are religious
because actually most people are chapter
6 and why are most people moral to the
extent that people are chapter 7 the
good book and the changing moral
zeitgeist I shall read a little bit from
that I'm keeping a tally of the people
walking out I think it's about three or
four seven
there are two ways in which scripture
might be a source of morals or rules for
living one is by direct instruction for
example through the 10 commandments
which are the subject of such bitter
contention in the culture wars of
America's boondocks the other is by
example God or some other biblical
character might serve as to use the
contemporary jargon a role-model
both scriptural roots if follow through
religiously encourage a system of morals
which any civilized modern person
whether religious or not would find I
can put it no more gently obnoxious
Abraham was the founding father of all
three great monotheistic religions his
patriarchal status renders him only
somewhat less likely than God to be
taken as a role model but what modern
moralist would wish to follow him God
ordered Abraham to make a burnt offering
of his longed for son Abraham built an
altar put firewood upon it and trust
Isaac up on top of the wood his
murdering life was already in his hand
when an angel dramatically intervened
with the news of a last-minute change of
plan
God was only joking after all tempting
Abraham and testing his faith a modern
moralist cannot help but wonder how a
child could ever recover from such
psychological trauma
by the standards of modern morality this
disgraceful story is an example
simultaneously of child abuse bullying
into asymmetrical power relationships
and the first recorded use of the
Nuremberg defense I was only obeying
orders yet the legend is one of the
great foundational myths of all three
monotheistic religions modern
theologians will protest that the story
of Abraham sacrificing Isaac should not
be taken as literal fact and the
appropriate response is twofold first
many many people even to this day do
take the whole of their scripture to be
literal fat and they have a great deal
of political power over the rest of us
especially in the United States and in
the Islamic world second if not as
literal fat how should we take the story
as an allegory that an allegory for what
surely nothing praiseworthy
as a moral lesson but what kind of
morals could one derive from this
appalling story remember all I'm trying
to establish for the moment is that we
do not as a matter of fact derive our
morals from Scripture or if we do we
pick and choose among the Scriptures for
the nice bits and reject the nasty but
then we must have some independent
criterion for deciding which are the
moral bits a criterion which wherever it
comes from cannot come from Scripture
itself and it's presumably available to
all of us whether we are religious or
not apologists even seek to salvage some
decency for the god character in this
deplorable tale wasn't it good of God to
spare Isaac's life at the last minute in
the unlikely event that any of my
readers are persuaded by this obscene
piece of special pleading
I refer them to another story of human
sacrifice which ended more unhappily in
judges chapter 11 the military leader
Jephthah made a bargain with God that if
God would guarantee just as victory over
the ammonites
Jephthah would without fail sacrifice as
a burnt offering whatsoever cometh for
of the doors of my house to meet me when
I return Jephthah did indeed defeat the
ammonites with a very great slaughter as
his par for the course in the book of
Judges and he returned home victorious
not surprisingly his daughter his only
child came out of the house to greet him
with timbrels and dances and alas she
was the first living thing to do so
understandably Jess for rent his clothes
but there was nothing he could do about
it
God was obviously looking forward to the
promised burnt offering and in the
circumstances the daughter very decently
agreed to be sacrificed
she asked only that she should be
allowed to go into the mountains for two
months to bewail her virginity at the
end of this time she meekly returned and
Jeff had cooked her God did not see fit
to intervene on this occasion God's
monumental rage whenever his chosen
people flirted with a rival God
resembled nothing so much as sexual
jealousy of the worst kind and again it
should strike a modern moralist as far
from good role model material the
temptation to sexual infidelity is
readily understandable even to those who
do not succumb and it's a staple of
fiction and drama from Shakespeare to
bedroom farce but the apparently
irresistible temptation to [ __ ] with
foreign gods is something we moderns
find harder to empathize with to my
naive eyes thou shalt have no other gods
but me would seem an easy enough
commandment to keep a doddle one might
think compared with thou shalt not covet
thy neighbor's wife or her ass or her ox
yet throughout the Old Testament with
the same predictable regularity as in
bedroom farce God had only to turn his
back for a moment and the children of
Israel would be off and at it with Bale
or some trollop of a graven image or on
some on one calamitous occasion a golden
calf there then follows a section on
Moses which I'm going to cut go on to
the end of the Moses section the ethnic
cleansing begun in the time of Moses is
brought to bloody fruition in the book
of Joshua a text remarkable for the
bloodthirsty massacres it records and
the xenophobic relish with which it does
so as the charming old song exultant Lee
has it Joshua fit the Battle of Jericho
and the walls came a tumbling down
there's none like good old Joshua at the
Battle of Jericho good old Joshua didn't
rest until they utterly destroyed all
that was in the city both man and woman
young and old and ox and sheep and ass
with the edge of the sword Joshua 6:21
yet again theologians will protest it
didn't happen
well no the story has it that the walls
came tumbling down at the mere sound of
men shouting and blowing horns so indeed
it didn't happen but that is not the
point the point is that whether true or
not the Bible is held up to us as the
source of our morality and the Bible
story of Joshua's destruction of the
Layton's realm of Jericho and the
invasion of the promised land in general
is morally indistinguishable from
Hitler's invasion of Poland or Saddam
Hussein's massacres of the Kurds and the
Marsh Arabs the Bible may be an
arresting and poetic work of fiction
but it is not the sort of book you
should give your children to form their
morals as it happens the story of Joshua
in Jericho is the subject of an
interesting experiment in child morality
by the Israeli psychologist George
Cameron
Tamaran presented to more than a
thousand Israeli school children aged
between eight and fourteen the book of
Joshua's account of the Battle of
Jericho he then asked the children a
simple moral question do you think
Joshua and the Israelites acted rightly
or not they had to choose between a
total approval be partial approval and C
total disapproval the results were
polarized 66 percent gave total approval
and 26% total disapproval with rather
fewer eight percent in the middle with
partial approval here are three typical
answers from the total approval a group
in my opinion Joshua and the sons of
Israel acted well and here are the
reasons God promised them this land and
gave them permission to conquer if they
would not have acted in this manner or
killed anyone then there would be the
danger that the sons of Israel would
have assimilated among the [ __ ] in my
opinion Joshua was right when he did it
one reason being that God commanded him
to exterminate the people so that the
tribes of Israel will not be able to
assimilate amongst them and learn their
bad ways Joshua did good because the
people who inhabited the land were of a
different religion and when Joshua
killed them he wiped their religion from
the earth the justification for the
genocide or massacre by Joshua is
religious in every case even those in
category C who gave total disapproval
did so in some cases for backhanded
religious reasons one girl for example
disapproved of Joshua's conquering
Jericho because in order to do so he had
to enter it I think it is bad since the
Arabs are impure and if one enters an
impure land one will also become impure
and share their curse tamarin ran a
fascinating control group in his
experiment a different group of 168
Israeli children were given the same
text from the book of Joshua
but the Joshua's own name replaced by
General Lin
and Israel replaced by a Chinese Kingdom
3,000 years ago now the experiment gave
opposite results only seven percent
approved of general Lin's behavior and
seventy-five percent disapproved in
other words when their loyalty to
Judaism was removed from the calculation
the majority of the children agreed with
the moral judgments that most modern
humans would share
Joshua's action was a deed of barbaric
genocide but it all looks different from
a religious point of view and the
difference starts early in life it was
religion that made the difference
between the children condemning genocide
and condoning it do those people who
hold up the Bible as an inspiration to
moral rectitude have the slightest
notion of what is actually written in it
the following offenses merit the death
penalty according to Leviticus 20
cursing your parents committing adultery
making love to your stepmother or your
daughter-in-law homosexuality marrying a
woman and her daughter best eality
and to add injury to insult the
unfortunate beast is to be killed too
you also get executed of course for
working on the Sabbath the point is made
again and again throughout the Old
Testament in numbers 15 the children of
Israel found a man in the wilderness
gathering sticks on the forbidden day
they arrested him and then asked God
what to do with him as it turned out
God was in no mood for half-measures
that day and the Lord said unto Moses
the man shall surely be put to death all
the congregation shall stone him with
stones without the camp and all the
congregation brought him without the
camp and stoned him with stones and he
died did this harmless gatherer of
firewood have a wife and children to
grieve for him did he whimper with fear
as the first stones flew and scream with
pain as the fusillade crashed into his
head what shocks me today about such
stories is not that they rarely happen
they probably didn't what makes my jaw
drop is that people today should base
their lives on such an appalling role
model as Yahweh and even worse that they
should ba Sallee try to force the same
evil monster with a fact or fiction on
the rest of us I'm going to skip the
remaining chapters now to the last
chapter at the very last section of the
last chapter the mother of all burkas
one of the unhappiest spectacles to be
seen on our streets today is the image
of a woman swathe in shapeless black
from head to toe peering out of the
world through a tiny slit I should say
that the streets that I normally walk
are the streets of England it probably
isn't the case here the burqa is not
just an instrument of oppression of
women and classical repression of their
Liberty and their beauty not just a
token of egregious male cruelty and
tragically cowed female submission I
want to use the narrow slit in the veil
as a symbol of something else our eyes
see the world through a narrow slit in
the electromagnetic spectrum visible
light is a [ __ ] of brightness in the
vast dark spectrum from radio waves at
the long end to gamma rays at the short
end quite how narrow is hard to
appreciate and a challenge to convey
imagine a giant black burqa with a
vision slit of approximately the
standard width say about one inch if the
length of black cloth above the slit
represents the shortwave end of the
invisible spectrum and if the length of
black cloth below the slit represents
the long-wave portion of the invisible
spectrum how long would the burka have
to be in order to accommodate a one inch
slit to the same scale it's hard to
represent it sensibly without invoking
logarithmic scales so huge are the
lengths we're dealing with the last
chapter of a book like this is no place
to start tossing logarithms around but
you can take it from me that it would be
the mother of all burkas the one-inch
window of visible light is derisive
early tiny compared with the miles and
miles of black cloth representing the
invisible part of the spectrum from
radio waves of the hem of the skirt to
gamma rays at the top of the head what
science does for us is to widen the
window it opens up so wide that the
imprisoning black garment drops away
almost completely exposing our senses to
airy and exhilarating freedom optical
telescopes use glass lenses and mirrors
to scan
the heavens and what they see as stars
that happen to be radiating in the
narrow band of wavelengths that we call
visible light but other telescopes see
in the x-ray or radio wavelengths and
present to us a cornucopia of
alternative night skies on a smaller
scale cameras with appropriate filters
can see in the ultraviolet and take
photographs of flowers that show an
alien range of stripes and spots that
are visible - and seemingly designed for
insect eyes but which our unaided eyes
can't see at all insect eyes have a
spectral window of similar width to ours
but slightly shifted up the burka they
are blind to read and they see further
into the ultraviolet than we do into the
ultraviolet garden the metaphor of the
narrow window of light broadening out
into a spectacularly wide spectrum
serves us in other areas of science we
live near the center of a cavernous
Museum of magnitudes viewing the world
with sense organs and nervous systems
that are equipped to perceive and
understand only a small middle range of
sizes moving at a middle range of speeds
we are at home with objects ranging in
size from a few kilometers the view from
a mountaintop to about a tenth of a
millimeter the point of a pin outside
this range even our imagination is
handicapped which fortunately we could
and we need sorry outside this range
even our imagination is handicapped and
we need the help of instruments and
mathematics which fortunately we can
learn to deploy the range of sizes
distances or speeds with which our
imaginations are comfortable is a tiny
band set in the midst of a gigantic
range of the possible from the scale of
quantum strangeness of the smaller end
to the scale of einsteinium cosmology of
the larger our imaginations our
forlornly under-equipped to cope with
distances outside the narrow middle
range of the ancestrally familiar we try
to visualize an electron as a tiny ball
in orbit around a larger cluster of
balls representing
and neutrons that isn't what it is like
at all electrons are not like little
balls they are not like anything we
recognize it isn't clear that like even
means anything when we try to fly too
close to realities further horizons our
imaginations are not yet tooled up to
penetrate the neighborhood of the
quantum nothing of that scale behaves in
the way matter as we are evolved to
think or to behave
nor can we cope with the behavior of
objects that move at some appreciable
fraction of the speed of light common
sense lets us down because common sense
evolved in a world where nothing moves
very fast and nothing is very small or
very large the mundane world of the
familiar which I have dubbed middle
world at the end of a famous essay on
possible worlds the great biologist JBS
Haldane wrote now my own suspicion is
that the universe is not only queerer
than we suppose but queerer than we can
suppose I suspect that there are more
things in heaven and earth than are
dreamed of or can be dreamed of in any
philosophy how should we interpret all
Danes queerer than we can suppose queer
'van can in principle be supposed or
just queerer than we can suppose given
the limitation of our brains
evolutionary apprenticeship in middle
world could we by training and practice
emancipate ourselves from middle world
tear off our black worker and achieve
some sort of intuitive as well as just
mathematical understanding of the very
small the very large and the very fast I
genuinely don't know the answer but I'm
thrilled to be alive
at a time when humanity is pushing
against the limits of understanding even
better we may eventually discover that
there are no limits thank you very much
professor professor Dawkins we'll take
questions we'll ask you to line up at
the two microphones introduce yourself
and concisely ask your question it
possible to have the house lights up a
bit so I can see people are asking
questions hello is this microphone on
I'm dr. Howell it's good to have heard
your talk I really appreciated hearing
this I should like to hear more of you
because the more you talk the more you
convince me that there is a God and you
crystallize our need for him I'm glad I
have some effect as a scientist I'm a
bit disturbed that you would go on a
tirade for 40 minutes against God so he
couldn't let me go clearly I can't sure
as a scientist I'm a bit upset by the
fact that you would go on a 40-minute
tirade against God and then begin
talking of science as if to put the
authority of science into what you said
but I do have a question about your long
discussion about morality and it coming
from the Bible and that you accuse
people I suppose Christians of saying
that we get our morality from the
scriptures but clearly this cannot be
the case because humanity from every
civilization throughout time has a sense
of morality and clearly most of them
have had not have not had access to the
Bible so I'm curious then what you think
is the origin of this morality if
someone comes in here with a gun and
began shooting all of us we would call
that bad why why is that bad um I think
we probably agree that people don't as a
matter of fact get their morality from
scriptures and that's what I was
actually saying people get their
morality from somewhere quite other than
than the scriptures and to the extent
that they do get their morality from the
scriptures as I was saying they pick and
choose now if you're asking me where we
get our morality from I think that's an
extremely complicated question and one
that I'm very interested in I've got a
whole chapter on it in the book which I
didn't have time to read from I think
that a sort of bedrock of it probably
comes from our Darwinian heritage as a
kind of misfiring byproduct of our
Darwinian past when we lived
small villages or small roving bands
which meant that we were surrounded by
close kin and that as you no doubt know
is one good prerequisite for the
evolution of altruism under Darwinian
rules and also in those small villages
or roving bands we would have been
surrounded by people whom we are likely
to meet again and again throughout our
life which provides the basis for the
other main Darwinian reason to be moral
or altruistic that I think is the
Darwinian origin and I suspect that
although we no longer live in small
bands the same rule of thumb rules of
thumb which were honed in our Darwinian
past are playing themselves out under
the alien conditions of modern urban
society the rule of thumb used to be be
nice to everyone you meet because
everyone you meet is likely to be either
a cousin and/or somebody you're going to
meet again and again and therefore in a
position to reciprocate Darwinism
doesn't forecast doesn't suggest that we
should be all wise and do what is
actually going to be best for our
selfish genes instead it says that it
builds into our brains rules of thumb
which worked in our ancestral past that
rule of thumb you nice to everybody
is still in our brains it is a lust
which is rather similar to sexual lust
which is still in our brains even though
we may use contraception and therefore
are not actually using copulation to
reproduce the same rule of thumb
persists and that is also true of the
lust to be good the lust to be nice that
I think is the Darwinian origin but I
think that it's become modified and
refined through culture through
civilization until it shows itself in
the much more sophisticated and actually
much more pleasant rules for being nice
that we see today wherever else it comes
from it certainly doesn't come from
Scripture and that the only point I was
trying to make from that particular
reading
well hello there welcome to welcome to
America I've been reading your book I've
been reading your book and I think
you're a terrific writer and I got to
say listening to you in person in that
accent and everything man I just think
you're brilliant but I thought that'd be
about you I know I well it's it's
Lynchburg
well I am I am a theist you'll be
disappointed to know but he might you
know how Bertrand Russell you know said
that if he faced God he'd ask you know
where you know he didn't give enough
evidence where was the evidence on a
couple pieces of evidence that I would
just kind of be interested to hear hear
what you think about pertaining to this
issue of ethics I read this chapter on
ethics in your a book and I found it
interesting I mean you were dealing with
the the origin of our moral sense more
so than I think the origin of morality
itself you'd probably agree right so so
you know you still wonder what is it
about the world that makes some things
you know right and and something's wrong
something's good something's bad and you
know you want to retain the language of
some things are evil and you give a lot
of religious examples and I'm in
agreement with you and some of you know
but if we're going to retain these
categories these very strong you know
moral categories it seems to me that
naturalism is going to be very hard
pressed to kind of provide an account
for where real good and evil would be I
mean I'm not sure how entirely we can
simply assert the existence of value
without providing a deeper account for
it and one other moral freedom as well
it seems to me that if the naturalist is
kind of shackled you know I mean an a
chiral istic world it would seem as if
we're just bound and determined to
behave just the way that we do right if
morality is all about ought and ought
applies can how can we ever do anything
other than exactly what it is that we do
so I'd be real interest in your
responses to those things well I think
it's a problem for all of us I mean not
not just for naturalists I know I think
it is actually a fairly baffling where
our morality comes from and why we're in
fact as nice as we are in the
professionals in this field our moral
philosophers and moral philosophers that
the majority of them are are not
theologically
inclined I mean they tend to develop
ideas the simplest of all the one the
one we all know about is that is the
Golden Rule behave to others as you
would wish they should behave
you and moral philosophers have
developed other such principles always
oppose suffering always behave as if you
didn't know whether you were going to be
at the top of the pecking order or the
bottom these are all moral precepts
which moral philosophers have developed
now it's a genuinely difficult question
why any individual should wish to follow
such moral precepts if I ask myself I'm
actually a very moral person I think I'm
sure most of you are too if I ask myself
why I don't steal why I pay my taxes why
I do that all the things that keep
society going I suppose it's slightly
irrational feeling that I wouldn't wish
to live in the kind of society where
people behaved in the sort of ways that
I wouldn't wish them to bit to behave in
and therefore I shouldn't behave in
those ways either that isn't entirely
rational because if I behave in an
anti-social way then that doesn't
actually stop anybody else doing the
nice things to me that well it maybe it
does and that that could could be the
problem but it is a genuinely difficult
problem why we are moral all that I wish
to assert today is that is that religion
certainly doesn't help or if it does I
mean if there's anybody here who thinks
that their moral purely because they're
frightened of what God might do if
they're not I mean that's a pretty
contemptible reason to be moral and and
I don't think we probably have much
respect for people who only behave well
because of the great surveillance camera
in the sky so I think that that I'm sure
all all of us here are moral from for
better reasons than than that although I
quite agree with the questioner it's
genuinely difficult to decide why why we
are thank goodness we are
aving professor Dawkins my name is
Thomas illa Kowski I come from Thomas
Jefferson's University here to ask you a
question
Richard atheists have a PR problem they
are among the most distrusted minorities
in the u.s. many many people equate
atheism with immorality and pessimism
they ask what good has atheism done
atheism is so cold I don't find any
comfort from those who do not believe in
God
some have attempted to answer these
criticisms with new life stances such as
humanism or the Church of reality they
assert there will be there will not be
widespread apostasy until there is a
replacement for religion sam harris says
we must find ways of meeting our
emotional needs that do not require the
abject embrace of the of the
preposterous further he says we must
learn to invoke the power of ritual and
to mark those transitions in every human
life that demand profundity birth
marriage death without lying to
ourselves about the nature of reality so
my question is do you what is your view
of that assertion that there will not be
widespread apostasy until we find a
replacement for religion yes thank you
that's an extremely interesting question
a very important one if it is the case
that people find consolation and comfort
in religion then I'm not in the least
surprised but note that that doesn't in
any way imply that religious beliefs are
true what is comforting and what is true
are two entirely different things
important to get that out of the way
first because there are people I'm sorry
to say who can't tell the difference
between that which is comforting and
that which is true if you don't see the
point
imagine a doctor telling you you're
absolutely fine when actually you've got
terminal cancer there are people who
would wish their doctor to lie to them
but those people who would not wish
their doctor to lie to them should not
be sympathetic to the idea that the that
religion has value simply because it is
comforting more consoling now the
questioner quotes Sam Harris as by the
way I strongly recommend his books the
end of faith and letter to a Christian
nation both utterly brilliant books sam
harris says we need to replace the
various roles of religion comfort might
be one of them
ritual might be another rites of passage
marriages funerals and so on might be
another to the extent that humans do
need ritual and do need public meetings
to signal things like births marriages
and deaths I don't see any reason why we
shouldn't put on secular equivalents of
the religious ceremonies that mostly
dominate our lives at the moment I have
myself organized one secular funeral for
a very dearly loved colleague and been
to many others and what what we did and
what is normally done is to obvious
dispense with all prayers but you retain
music you retain poetry you can have
readings from the deceased person's
favorite books eulogies by people who
knew and loved the deceased person this
is not difficult to arrange it has the
smack of sincerity about it in a way
that prayers which are for the same
prayers
regardless of who they are the smack of
sincerity comes from the fact that
they're individually tailored to the
individual who's died whenever I've been
to religious funerals which have an
element of the non-religious about the
religious funerals which include
eulogies which include the deceased
favorite poetry etc I don't know about
you but my experience is that the
prayers for absolutely flat whereas the
eulogies and the poems are intensely
moving my wife even says thank goodness
for the prayers they are the one thing
that stops her from crying and keeps her
um amused almost rather than rather than
being sad about the loss of the
much-loved dead person the questioner is
absolutely right in his preamble when he
says that at least in American society
atheists are the least loved least
respected major group that's something
that's got to change
because atheists are far far more
numerous than most people realize and
that's mostly because they won't come
out of the closet
it's obvious that in an intelligent
educated audience such as this
University
I stress this University
who was it thought who was it saw fit to
give them accreditation I'd like to know
in a place like this I have not the
slightest doubt but there are a very
large number of atheists and agnostics
what is wrong with everybody in that
position throughout the country standing
up recognizing each other joining
together and forming I won't say a lobby
because somebody suggested that
organizing atheist is rather like
herding cats
they are on the whole too intelligent
and independent minded to lend
themselves to being herded but if a if
an atheist Lobby could be got together
which showed a small fraction of its
numerical strength it would outnumber
for example the Jewish lobby which is
formatively and notoriously powerful in
this country there are more secularists
agnostics and atheists in this country
than there are Jews but do they have a
voice in politics is it possible for an
atheist to get elected to high office in
this country no the Congress of this
country is presumably at least partly
derived from the intelligent educated
wing of the country that being so it is
statistically almost inconceivable that
a substantial number of members of
Congress are not atheists obviously many
of them must be and yet not single one
of them will admit it they are forced to
dissemble even to lie about their
religious convictions because that's the
only way they can get elected well isn't
that something that the American
electorate ought to be doing something
about so I accept the questioners
premise and suggest that it's up to I'm
not an American citizen so it's
unfortunately not up to me but up to
all of you to do something about it and
to change the status of atheists in this
country had to change the electability
of atheists in this country
good evening my name is Amy LeMay
Hammond I'm a first year student at our
MWC and sorry I didn't care that my name
is Amy LeMay Hammond I'm a first year
student at our MWC thank you and firstly
I'd like to thank you for recognizing
that there are probably many atheists in
this room and that we are not morally
dangerous or have no morals my question
is in the case of sort of mock religions
such as the invisible pink unicorn and
such which I'm sure you're familiar with
do those help the Atheist cause or do
they actually hurt it by creating sort
of hilarity about religion okay they do
they do one good thing they on sir one
question and it's a very important
question because it's a very ubiquitous
one it's the following question you
cannot disprove the existence of God now
amazingly there are a lot of people who
think that's a powerful argument
you cannot disprove the existence of God
which somehow seems to suggest to them
oh well therefore the existence of God
must be about equally likely to the to
the non exhibit existence and
non-existence must be approximately
equally likely and the point about the
invisible pink unicorn the Flying
Spaghetti Monster and the celestial
teapot and all those examples is simply
to demonstrate that it's just not the
case that because you cannot disprove
something therefore that makes it the
slightest bit likely and so that that's
that that's the sole purpose of them it
is a very important purpose thank
Hawkins um my name is Zack Smith I
happen to be from Liberty University and
I just want to applaud your uh your
atheist wit because I have never at the
same time been so insulted but amused at
the same time so I just want to say does
a good one but might I have to forego my
original question with the P R state of
the AC of atheists that uh you've you
know implied that there's some kind of
social justice issue at stake here by
saying that it's you know wrong or that
that ought to be and that kind of
language kind of implies that there is
some kind of moral standard now I'm
wondering if if you know from from your
perspective what kind of moral standard
could be a basis for that kind of social
justice if if indeed there's no higher
power I just oh well um first I don't
understand why you should feel insulted
I didn't insult you I was outed God and
that's a very different
but but then the question of of social
justice in the in the in the rights of
atheist to be considered citizens and to
be considered electable I don't think
the issue is is quite that they should
be elected because they are atheist that
wasn't the point the point is that being
an atheist should not debar you any more
than being black to go back in history
to being black or Jewish or Catholic or
a woman or any of the other things which
historically have tended to make
somebody unelectable and no longer do
I'm delighted to say that atheists and
indeed homosexuals which of which of
which are the next one made most
difficult lot to get elected but
atheists are the other sort of the last
major group to be embraced in this
charmed circle of the electable I'm not
saying they should be elected because
they're atheists I'm saying that that
that they should be free to openly say
what their religious conviction or lack
of conviction is and not thereby
instantly be unelectable that that's all
right that's all I meant I didn't mean
anything more than that
thank you I just would like to say at
the outside a thank you for for coming
and putting yourself in a sense on the
firing line insofar as you've taken on
God do you have always the opportunity
that God might win so I would like just
to call your attention to something that
in my hearing of your your talk you
mentioned in a sense of ridicule about
the Trinity and and its affront to
reason very difficult to understand even
make sense of and what you know why
would a person even try for that matter
but you interestingly enough you
finished your lecture with quantum
strangeness which in fact is the same
problem for scientists as the Trinity is
for believing Christians who have a need
to understand just making that comment
and and I'm recalled I spent most of my
life being an atheist or non-believer in
that sense and I've seen the world
through that lens and I understand the
logic of it and and so on when I became
a believer I also noticed that the same
world out there was being viewed through
a different metaphysical lens I would
suggest to you that there's a burqa as
well for metaphysical reality you can
shift up and look through faith or you
can shift down and look through human
intelligence or human understanding call
it reason or intuition or whatever but I
would call to your attention that there
is a whole new reality that comes it's
not supernatural in the sense but it's a
shift in understanding yes I think
that's a very interesting point and I
can answer it with reference to how you
began which was the comparison between
quantum theory which is deeply
mysterious and the mystery of the
Trinity and you implied that there's a
sort of comparability between those that
they are both deeply mysterious so why
should one prefer one over the other the
answer to that is actually very simple
quantum theory yields experimental
predictions
which have been verified to an accuracy
number of decimal places so accurate
that the great theoretical physicist
Richard Fineman compared it to the
accuracy of predicting the width of
North America to the accuracy of the
width of one human hair that is why
quantum theory has to be taken seriously
and it doesn't matter well it does
matter but it's some one can take in one
stride because of the brilliance of the
experimental verification it doesn't
matter that quantum theory is so
mysterious
that as Fineman himself once said if you
think you understand quantum theory
you don't understand quantum theory it
is true that the human mind and I
believe the reason is that the human
mind evolved in middle world where the
strangeness of quantum theory never
impinged upon human life it is true that
the human mind cannot grasp cannot
visualize cannot imagine the assumptions
that quantum theory need needs to make
but human physicists doing experiments
can verify the predictions of quantum
theory to an accuracy which is utterly
stupefying and which leaves one in no
doubt that in some sense quantum theory
must be right nothing remotely like that
could ever be claimed for the doctrine
of the Trinity nor by the way is the
doctrine of the Trinity anything like so
interestingly mysterious as quantum
theory
hello thank you for coming to Lynchburg
My name is Matthew Warner I'm a grad
student at Liberty University I've won
one question going back to ethics and
morality you essentially said that the
Darwinian reason we have morality is
that back in the day you had cousins and
people you want to beat them to
reciprocate in order to act like that
you would have to make decisions
decisions would have to be based on
critical thinking I was wondering if you
have a Darwinian response or explanation
for how critical thinking relates to
Darwin Nina's right I think I understand
you you're the question is not really
about morality that the question is
about is there a similar Darwinian
account of critical thinking which is at
the basis of your explanation for
morality in my mind my explanation for
everything else busy will be as well not
not just morality well I mean critical
thinking is is something which isn't
universally an attribute of the human
mind it's
I don't think it's very very hard to
imagine that I imagine ways in which
critical thinking could have benefited
the survival of our ancestors I mean I I
think that taking a rational view of
evidence would probably have helped our
ancestors to survive in a world of
saber-tooth Tigers and ice ages and
drying up water holes and all the other
things which all the other hazards which
threatened life I would have thought
rather the reverse that the problem that
faces us is how do we explain uncritical
lack of thinking why is there such a lot
of that about
and I I mean I do have a chapter
explaining that but actually thought
that was that was a rather harder
problem than than the one about about
critical thinking
hi my name is Carl Swenson and I'm going
to tip my hand right off to start like
the other brave questioners and say that
if if theories and ideas around things
like intelligent design creationism are
scientifically all but dead they just
haven't fallen over yet then I see
something else waiting in the wings
scientifically that needs that would
could be a problem for science and
that's until I ask your opinion about
this thing's like you've used the word
mind a lot we think of mind as some
dimensionless thing in the middle of our
head which tells us what to do in is
separate from the brain which is similar
to the soul another popular notion so
what is science or philosophy at this
point have to say about this about about
the mind about yeah about the existence
of it or the soul or the popular notions
well I mean my view would be a
materialistic one not everybody's would
and and my view would be that mind and
soul and consciousness and all those
sorts of words are they describe
something which is a manifestation of
the material brain and doesn't have any
existence outside material brains where
material brains could at some future
date perhaps include silicon brains not
not just neuronal brains but there has
to be some sort of physical medium
doubtless highly complicated highly
interconnected a network of of
complicated wiring diagram which by some
means which neurophysiologists are now
working on results in the phenomena
which psychologists study and which we
colloquially give names like mind
even so too so I don't think that the
mind is an immaterial thing that has any
existence outside the material world I
March Nadezhda I'm a sophomore at
randolph-macon Woman's College majoring
in biology and environmental science my
question is in no way controversial it's
not intended to be so and it basically
Springs out of what the point you made
in your hypothesis about God do you
imply that we made evolve to become God
or do we share a common ancestry with
God well I don't think it's very helpful
to suggest that we're likely to evolve
to become gods I do think that there may
very well be somewhere in the universe
being evolved beings which are so far
advanced compared to us that we would if
we saw them we might very well be
tempted to call them gods and it is also
possible by the same token that if a
species goes on evolving either
genetically and/or culturally for a
sufficient number of millennia our
descendants might become so advanced
that we would be tempted to call them
gods however I don't think I would wish
to call them gods because however
advanced they are however ingenious
however intelligent however and their
technology would strike us with all they
would still be evolved beings they would
be beings that had evolved by a process
of slow gradual incremental evolution
and that to me is the diagnostic feature
of a God and God doesn't evolve and God
just happens and God is just there
and so I think my answer to your
question is it's an interesting thought
but in but but actually I don't think it
would be a helpful use of the word God
any more than if a Stone Age hunter
which who suddenly be transported into
the 21st century and would of course be
awestruck by computers and mobile phones
and Boeing 747s and helicopters and
rockets to the moon that Stone Age
hunter might be tempted to call us gods
but I think it's a temptation that he
should resist and so should we
dr. Dawkins I am a professor at Liberty
University of a non subject religion
right but according to your book and
I've been reading your book and it's
helped me to understand atheist mind I
appreciate that I have a whole group of
my students here tonight they've been in
the back there and because I wanted them
to hear what you have to say and we want
to be careful not to set up straw men
about atheists which you know are done
and I want them to avoid very much okay
sue but I wanted to read from your book
you'd be reading from your book and I
find it interesting this footnote on
page 82 we might be seeing something
similar today in it over publicized
Durga zation of the philosopher Anthony
flue who announced in his old age that
he had been converted to believe in some
sort of deity now I want to read that
footnote before I like question right
you would consider yourself a de facto
atheist leaning toward a strong atheist
category six leaning towards seven
apparently because you would say the
evidence demands your being an atheist
NOT a theist for you the evidence makes
the existence of God highly improbable
so my question is what evidence would
you need to conclude that God's
existence at least was as probable as
that of extraterrestrials and why did
you relegate Anthony flu to a footnote
with with him being such an eminent
philosopher and finding design in the
DNA an indication yea deity um Anthony
flu is a is a British philosopher who
has long been a champion of atheism and
he has as the questioner remarks
announced in his old age that he has
been converted to a form of deism not
out-and-out theism a form of deism where
he thinks there probably is some kind of
mysterious intelligence at the root of
the universe
many great people have thought the same
what disappointed me about Anthony flus
reasons for that is that he publicly
admitted publicly announced that what
had convinced him was the idea of
intelligent design and specifically the
book of Michael Behe well that doesn't
argue for the surviving powers that
Antony flew once had as an intellectual
and no serious thinker could possibly be
positively impressed by the arguments of
the so-called intelligent design
creationists there may be good reasons
for believing in a god and if there are
any I would expect them to come from
possibly modern physics from cosmology
from the observation that some people
claim the laws and constants of the
universe are too finely tuned to to be
an accident that would not be a wholly
disreputable reason for believing in
some form of supernatural deity I think
there's a very good argument against it
and I've developed much of my chapter
4-2 as I think refuting that argument if
utterly fluid said that then I think we
could have a serious argument with him
but what he actually said was that he
was convinced by intelligent design in
biology and anybody who knows anything
about biology and will immediately see
that that is ridiculous
I'm sorry to be so I'm sorry to be so
harsh but when I last saw Antony flu he
he didn't endear himself to me because
he actually went about promulgating the
legend that Darwin himself had a
deathbed conversion and that really is a
ridiculous story which was long long ago
disposed of by the Darwin family and it
led me to somewhat discount other things
that Anthony flu is now saying he once
was a great philosopher it's very sad
good evening my name is Ryan Thomas I'm
a biology major at Liberty University
and I kind of have a tube I kind of have
it I'm sorry I having a hard time
hearing oh I'm sorry I my name is Ryan
yes I'm a biology major at University at
Liberty University right now and I have
a two-part question for if you don't
mind my first question would be do you
draw a distinction in between blind
faith and reasonable faith okay is there
a distinction do I draw a distinction
between blind faith and reasonable faith
no
it's it's it's interesting that you say
that because just through my own studies
through my my investigation into this
matter I have come to the conclusion
there is no such thing as proof right
that there is reasonable faith and there
is blind faith when I when I drop a ball
you know to the ground on earth it's
reasonable for me to believe that the
ball will fall the very next time that I
drop it but I can't prove it just as I
can't prove that you exist yeah I
believe that you exist based on a
reasonable faith because I can see you
because I can hear you but our senses
can sometimes deceive us people on
cocaine feel bugs in their skin but that
doesn't make it real if people that are
taking hallucinogens see things but it
doesn't make it real okay so I think
it's interesting that you deny the the
line between reasonable fears I mean I
think we agree I think we're just using
words in a different way I think it's a
it's a semantic thing something like
when you when you drop a ball it falls
and you drop another ball it falls when
you drop another ball it falls I don't
think I would wish to use the word faith
for your belief that the next time you
drop it it will fall I don't think
that's what I would use the word faith
for I think that's that's and that's
normal science I mean that's based upon
Newton's laws it's based upon a
tremendous body of theory it's based
upon scientific evidence so I would not
use the word reasonable faith the way
you're using it seems to be you're using
reasonable faith for basing beliefs upon
upon evidence so if if you're using a
reasonable faith to mean belief based
upon evidence then there's no
disagreement we're just using words in a
different way I define faith as as
belief that's not based upon evidence
okay and that's why I answered your
first question in the way that I that I
did I don't think we actually disagree
and I'm sure we disagree at other things
but only we disagree about this in that
in in an other than semantic way okay
then my second question arms I didn't
expect you to answer no actually do the
first one but yeah
the surprises every day my second
question is considering them that we
must believe what's based on reason and
reason of course is based on experience
correct you know reason is is based on
the fact that when I when I drop the
ball it it falls every time so it's
reasonable to believe next time I drop
the ball it's going to fall
why then is it reasonable considering
our experience concerning the law of
cause and effect concerning the fact
that we our experience tells us that
everything which has an effect has a
cause how is it that it's more
reasonable to believe that the universe
created itself because when confined to
the natural laws because nature is bound
by its own limits which which are the
natural laws and if nature is bound by
the laws which say that matter can't
create itself then how do you get around
this issue that there must have been
something outside outside the system it
is it is very difficult it is of course
a very difficult question to ask how
things began at the very beginning of
the universe it's very difficult to even
know what the word beginning even means
with respect to the universe that any
physicist any biologist any scientist
any reasonable person would accept
however when you ask what's the
alternative
if the alternative that's being offered
to what physicists now talk about a big
a big bang a spontaneous singularity
which gave rise to the origin of the
universe if the alternative to that is a
divine intelligence a creator which
would have to have been complicated
statistically improbable the very kind
of thing which scientific theories such
as Darwin's exists to explain then
immediately we see that however
difficult and apparently inadequate the
theory of the physicists is the theory
of the theologians that the first cause
was a complicated intelligence is even
more different
to accept they're both difficult but the
theory of the cosmic intelligence is
even worse
what Darwinism does is to raise our
consciousness to the power of science to
explain the existence of complex things
and intelligences and creative
intelligences are above all complex
things they're statistically improbable
Darwinism raises our consciousness to
the power of science to explain how such
entities in the human brain is one how
such entities can come into existence
from simple beginnings however difficult
those simple beginnings may be to accept
they are a whole lot easier to accept
than complicated beginnings complicated
things come into the universe late as a
consequence of slow gradual incremental
steps God if he exists would have to be
a very very very complicated thing
indeed so to postulate a God as the
beginning of the universe as the answer
to the riddle of the first cause is to
shoot yourself in the conceptual foot
because you are immediately postulating
something far far more complicated than
that which you are trying to explain now
physicists cope with this problem in
various ways which may seem to you they
even seem to me somewhat unconvincing
for example they suggest that our
universe is but one bubble in a foam of
universes the multiverse and each bubble
in the foam has a different set of laws
and constants and by the anthropic
principle we have to be since we're here
talking about it we have to be in the
kind of bubble with the kind of laws and
constants which are capable of giving
rise to the evolutionary process and
therefore to creatures like us
that is one current physicist
explanation for how we exist in the kind
of universe that we that we
it doesn't sound so shatteringly
convincing as say Darwin's own theory
which is self-evidently very convincing
nevertheless however unconvincing that
may sound it is many many many orders of
magnitude more convincing than any
theory that says complex intelligence
was there right from the outset if you
if you have problems seeing how matter
could just come into existence try
thinking about how complex intelligent
matter or complex intelligent entities
of any kind could suddenly spring into
existence it's many many orders of
magnitude harder to understand sorry
you've had three already
hi my name is amber more from Liberty
University as well I have two questions
for you how can you believe in
extraterrestrials as a higher being and
not believe in a God could you just say
that again how can you how can you
believe as entra extraterrestrials as a
higher being and not believe in a God
how can I believe that an
extraterrestrial is a higher being and
not believe in them as a as an advanced
higher being yeah I understand the words
of your questions
an extraterrestrial higher being if one
exists comes into existence as the end
product of a long slow gradual
incremental process of evolution just
like the one that gave rise to us that's
the explanation for why the
extra-terrestrial if it is indeed an
advanced being is an advanced being it's
a very sensible easy to understand
explanation it's a gradual explanation
you start from simple beginnings and you
work up God isn't like that God is a
being that is not supposed to be evolved
God is a being that has always existed
and therefore does not have the benefit
of that kind of sensible rational
gradual istic explanation that is an
absolutely crucial difference I suspect
that on other planets there probably are
beings as I said before which are so far
advanced relative to us that they might
as well be gods except for this one
absolutely crucial respect but they came
into the universe by slow gradual
degrees
they didn't just happen nothing as
complicated as that just happens they
didn't just happen and therefore they or
it or he or she could not be responsible
for designing the universe
it's probably going to be the most
simplest one for you to answer but what
if you're wrong well what if I'm wrong I
mean anybody could be wrong we could all
be wrong about the Flying Spaghetti
Monster and the pink unicorn and the
flying teapot um you happen to have been
brought up I would presume in the
Christian faith you know what it's like
not to believe in a particular faith
because you're not a Muslim you're not a
Hindu why aren't you a Hindu because you
happen to be brought up in America not
in India if you've been brought up in
Hindu in India
you'd be a Hindu if you were brought up
in in Denmark in the time of the Vikings
you'd be believing in what an and Thor
if you brought up in in classical Greece
you'd be believing in Seuss if you
brought up in central Africa you'd be
believing in the great juju of the
mountain in there's no particular reason
to pick on the judeo-christian God in
which by the sheerest accident you
happen to have been brought up and asked
me the question what if I'm wrong what
if you're wrong about the great juju at
the bottom of the sea
in continuation of the last fellow's
questions the problem is that you're
applying natural laws to God whereas he
claims to exist outside of them
therefore he does not necessary to begin
until mean you talk your way out of
having to provide a rational argument by
just decreeing by Fiat but God but that
God simply declares himself outside
matter and therefore doesn't need the
same kind of argument as as anything
else if you're convinced by that kind of
thing you're welcome
my name is Kay Goodman and I'd like to
hear your thoughts on whether or not
there is a god or gods what effect has
it upon humankind upon the orders of the
world upon men and women that we rather
consistently refer to God as a male well
that's a perfectly fair point and I I
mean to me to me there there is no
difference between a non-existent male
and a non-existent
to the extent that to the extent that
god or gods has sociological
psychological political significance
then I could easily imagine that if one
could somehow begin a cult of a female
god it might well have a very improving
of effect upon human society
I'm nervous
amber dawn student here at
randolph-macon thank you for that
previous answer I'll give you a bit of
reprieve I am not challenging you in any
way shape or form and I only wrote this
down because I knew I'd forget what I
want to as someone coming from a
religious family especially in an area
with such a dominant religion and a
particular figurehead
how does someone find their own way when
leaving is not quite an option I didn't
quite the lost center yes how does one
find their own way when leaving just yet
is not quite an option okay first and I
have a small I think this is a very
serious question because I've had I've
had letters from really quite a lot of
people in especially in America and they
say things like I I'm actually an
atheist but I don't admit it I'm
frightened of my family I'm frightened
of my parents I'm frightened of my
minister I read an article the other day
about a boy in a small town in Texas who
didn't want to be confirmed and the
priest said well that's okay you don't
have to be confirmed but you have to
write down your reasons for not being
confirmed why did the boy have to write
down his reasons for not being confirmed
into that particular church you didn't
have to write down his reasons for not
being bar Mitzvahed as a Jew it just so
happened that he was born into a
Christian family and therefore the
presumption was made that he'd better
have a good reason for not being
confirmed into the religion of his
parents or else and that's one of the
main problems we have is the assumption
that our society makes regardless of
whether we are religious or not we all
buy into the convention that children
belong to the religion of their parents
you will see newspaper article
about Christian children and Muslim
children and Jewish children children
who may be as young as 3 or 4 years old
and who are therefore obviously much too
young to know what their beliefs are
about the cosmos and humanity and
religion there is no such thing as a
Christian child there is only a child of
Christian parents whenever you hear the
phrase Christian child or Muslim child
or Protestant child or Catholic child
the phrase should great like fingernails
on a blackboard
just as the feminists have raised our
consciousness to phrases like one-man
one-vote you can't hear that phrase now
without sort of at least wincing
slightly because you realize it should
be one-person one-vote at present we
haven't had our consciousness raised
about the labeling of children with the
religion of their parents that's just
one aspect and it shows itself to return
to the questioner it shows itself in a
great deal of difficulty that any young
person has in any person of any age has
in departing from the religion of their
parents their social groups their
grandparents their uncles and aunts and
so on it might be a bit like getting
divorced I mean it's sort of something
that raises real social problems there's
a magnificent one-woman show by the
comic actress Julia Sweeney called
letting go of God in which she describes
her own journey from Catholic upbringing
to the mature and balanced atheist that
she is today and she describes the
difficulty of admitting to her family
that that she had become an atheist it
actually was reported in in a newspaper
and her mother read it and screamed down
the telephone
I'm Julia Sweeney it's very witty a very
funny performance she does she says her
mother was absolutely horrified not
believing in God was one thing but an
atheist I don't know what the answer is
the I mean the president of gay people
is one that one can vaguely bear in mind
I mean homosexuality is now much much
more accepted in our society than it was
when I was young when I mean
homosexuality was actually illegal in
Britain up until I think the 1960s
believe it or not and the great British
mathematician one of the two fathers of
the modern computer Alan Turing who
arguably because of his brilliance in
solving the German Enigma codes in the
Second World War did more to win the
second world war than either Churchill
or Eisenhower Alan Turing was arrested
for homosexual behavior in the 1950s and
was essentially driven to suicide that
has now changed and now people can be
openly gay the word gay has become a
word used with pride rather than with
shame I think that we do have to have a
shift in social attitudes to atheism
which will mirror that towards
homosexuality it is after all just a
view about the cosmos and about some
very subtle things about humanity about
morality is really quite extraordinary
but somebody's view about such an
academic matter as whether there exists
as supreme intelligence should reflect
upon their the way they looked at in
society the way their family and their
friends look at them it is quite
remarkable that that should be the case
once again it's something we've all got
to do something about
last question very simple is anger a
common symptom of a person who is going
through the deconditioning process of
their parents religion I didn't go to
close to the microphone I said is anger
a common symptom of a person who is
going through the deconditioning process
of their parents relating his anger a
common symptom of a person who's going
through the deconditioning process from
their parents religion I don't know
I had never occurred to me does anybody
else have personal I think sort of fear
is is probably more common I mean fear a
fear of what their parents are going to
think rather than anger but but I could
be wrong and I'm interested in that if
that's that's question is based on
personal experience I'd be interested to
hear more
is that a common experience Wow an anger
on the part of the person who is
undergoing the deconversion themselves
anger against whom or what
and after night to the child reason
right well thank you that's extremely
interesting I've learned something this
evening thank you
hi I'm Ron I'm Ron Fineman I love
physics - two quick two questions if I
may at Liberty University they have on
display some fossils that they say are I
might be off by a factor or by thousand
years or so but they say these fossils
of dinosaurs are three thousand years
old maybe four thousand maybe five
thousand my my question the first
question to you is what what could they
do to really prove to scientists that
those fossils are indeed that old only
that's number one and then number two
would you be willing to elucidate a
little bit further your arguments
against creation by design and maybe
give us some better sense of
cosmological time just how long it
really is right the the belief that
dinosaurs are only three thousand years
old and that the universe is only six
thousand years old how to give an idea
of the real timespan of the world when
what one way to put it which I've
recently been think thinking about is
that if somebody believes that the world
is only six thousand years old or of the
order of a few thousand years old when
the true age of the earth is of the
order of a few billion years old that
means they are out by a factor of a
million
which is not a trivial error it's I mean
I am not very good at arithmetic and I
calculated that it's equivalent to
believing that the distance from New
York to San Francisco is seven hundred
yards but I received a letter from a
mathematician who done is done the sum
again and he said I got it wrong
it's actually equivalent to believing
that the distance from New York to San
Francisco is 28 feet either way it gives
you an idea of the scale of the error
the questioner asked what would the
people of Liberty University have to do
in order to demonstrate that these
dinosaur fossils really were 3000 years
old or what they would have to do is to
find igneous rocks which were found in
proximity toward sandwiching the fossils
and date these by radioactive dating
several different half a dozen at least
different forms of radioactive dating
all of which give independent estimates
of the date of these fossils and all
those different methods of doing it
should point to an age of 3000 years in
fact of course what they methods of
dating or show is that dinosaur fossils
are hundreds of millions no less than 65
million years old not just one method of
radioactive dating lots and lots of
different methods of radioactive dating
different clocks clocks working on
completely different principles that
that all point to the same order of
magnitude of age of these dinosaur
fossils if it's really true that the
Museum at Liberty University has
dinosaur fossils which are labeled as
being 3000 years old
then that is an educational disgrace
it is divulging
the whole idea of a university and I
would strongly encourage any members of
Liberty University who may be here to
leave and go to a proper University
with your with elucidating on chance
versus natural selection versus
intelligent design and give us a sense
of rajma logical time chance and natural
selection and intelligent design one of
the biggest fallacies in popular
understanding of Darwinian evolution by
natural selection is that it is a theory
of random chance it is not it's the it's
the very opposite and this is one of the
most important things to understand
about it there is a certain chance
element in it the mutation is is a
process of random charges random with
respect to improvement things don't tend
to get better as a result of mutation
the important step in the Darwinian
theory of evolution is natural selection
natural selection is a non-random
process natural selection is the
non-random survival of randomly varying
genetic codes and the reason why some
genetic codes survive better than others
is their phenotypic effects via the
processes of embryogenesis on phenotypes
on bodies which make them survive will
not survive reproduce or not survive and
the ones that do survive and reproduce
pass on the genetic coded instructions
that built them and equipped them and
made them good at surviving and
reproducing that's the idea that is the
explanation for the apparent adaptive
design if that the illusion of design
which all living things show it is a
non-random process it does not involve
design of any sort and it produces an
illusion of design it is hard for people
to grasp for various reasons and one
reason the questioner has pinpointed is
the sheer length of time involved
geological time is larger than most
human minds are capable of grasping one
there various metaphors have been used
to
convey the sheer magnitude of geological
time one that I like which I didn't
invent is you hold out your hand to
represent the the length of geological
time to say the middle of my tie is the
origin of life and the tip of my finger
is the present then the dinosaurs which
went extinct 65 million years ago lived
about there most of this is bacteria you
have you have multicellular life
evolving about here dinosaurs about
there humans at my fingernail and the
whole of recorded human history
everything from the Egyptians biblical
times the Romans the Assyrians the
Greeks all of human history disappears
in the dust from one stroke of a nail
file that's the the scale of human
history is the dust from one stroke of a
nail file on the same scale as the time
that's available that has been available
for evolution that is one of the reasons
why people find it so hard to understand
there are many reasons I've written
about eight books on the subject which
preceded the God Delusion
and it's a little hard to condense it
into a few minutes thank you very much
I'm sorry I don't know when we're
supposed to stop and I'm we went out
professor Dawkins is going to sign books
for us after this down and ruble lounge
which is downstairs to give him a few
minutes to get there but I think we
probably better stop here here for this
evening okay thank you very much